what was the best piece of advice on
writing you've ever received gosh I
think there have been a lot over the
years or whatever you know I think
trusting your actors you know I think is
really really kind of important you know
as a writer trusting the actor's
instincts about you know either the line
or about the moment or about any subtext
I think it's really important sorry so
that's great let's sorry to interrupt so
so when you said again the best answer
wins best idea so if an actor has a
suggestion and it's not on the script
but it's set in in the moment yeah
sometimes you're like you know what I
like that let's go with that you know I
think for me you know this gets into a
whole kind of like discussion but for me
I think I think there are reliable
writers and unreliable writers you know
I think I think as an actor when you
pick up a script from a writer that you
don't know there are ways of telling you
know whether that writer is reliable and
if that right for me if that writer is
reliable then you kind of put your
instincts you know to the side and
follow this writer is kind of like map
and see where it leads and then you know
along the way you might have some
questions whatever and then you might
get a script where the writer is clearly
not reliable and so you have to kind of
measure the essence of the story measure
the essence of the writers intentions
and keep your instincts close to you so
that you can kind of let your instincts
guide you a little bit you know so you
know that's that's the way that I kind
of approach things as an actor so as a
writer I would hope that most
actors who read my scripts can tell that
I'm a reliable writer and so I think
that buys you a little bit of time in
letting the actor kind of follow you on
your journey and trusting your instincts
and then along the way you know there
might be some discussion about that
scene doesn't work or where is that line
coming from and then you might you know
be proven wrong and that happens you
know naturally I think over the years
for me I think when I first started
writing I was really kind of specific
about the world that I wanted to create
the scene that I wanted to create I
wanted to kind of really dot all the i's
and cross all the t's and then I think
as I've written more and more as I've
you know kind of grown as you know
storyteller I've kind of been more
comfortable with letting go of some of
that stuff and and letting and letting
kind of like things get figured out you
know during during the process of either
rehearsal or filming or whatever so
trusting the actors a little bit I think
is good you know not spelling everything
out I think is important you know
something that I've learned and I think
I mean these are not really advice kind
of like comments that I've received but
it's more things that I've learned I
don't know if that makes sense but for
me when I first started writing I I had
all these secrets that I wanted to keep
and they were my secrets about as the
writer and I didn't really want to share
it with the audience and then you know
and then I even the more I've written
ever you realize that you have to share
things with the audience that's the
relationship you have to be careful of
what you share and you have to decide
when you want to share it but you have
to share things with the audience
otherwise they're not interested
invested they're confused whatever so I
think trusting the audience is right up
there with trusting the actors you know
is really kind of like letting things go
a little bit not spelling everything out
and hoping that you know that either the
actors will do the rest of the work for
you or the audience will do the rest of
the work for you I think that's I think
that's I think that's important you know
what do you trust in the audience with
again figuring out the subtext or not
needing to spell everything out you know
I think the the challenge with any kind
of work of art I think is the the minute
you you begin the process of creating
that that work of art or that product or
whatever you start to lose perspective
you know and I think that is an inherent
part of the process but it's also
something that that you know we have to
be aware of as soon as you start going
into the cave and the more you walk
toward this kind of finished product the
deeper you are into this cave and you
start to like not know what you know
what what works and what what you know
what doesn't work you know so I think
trusting the audience that something
will work without having to spell
everything out I think it's probably a
good thing that I've learned you know is
that because as you go into this cave
you're getting further and further into
your own mind and so are you losing
perspective as how other people will see
it yeah I think so because I think when
you watch a movie you you you you don't
really know the writers you know
intentionally or you don't really know
you just sort of you're on this journey
and
I think you know when you are with the
story for a long time and you're raising
money for it and you're pitching this
story to so many different people and
you're shooting it and you know do you
want you're just so close to the product
you know you're so close to the story
that it you know some things you think
matter don't and some things that you
think don't resonate actually have a
really strong impact in the audience and
that's you know that's that's really
kind of hard to figure out you know what
secrets do you think they want to know
and why is it because they want to know
they're like you well what I what I
meant
initially was just kind of plot secrets
you know you know little things that you
think have kind of resonance or whatever
you know like you know the very first
play that I wrote back in 2004 I love
that play it had a lot of heart you know
and and it was really kind of like
special in its own way but when I read
it now you know I see all these kinds of
writer secrets you know I see all these
kinds of kind of really esoteric things
that matter to me as a writer but they
didn't really matter to the plot per se
you know and they didn't really have you
know an impact in the story you know and
so I think for that specific story as an
example you know some of those decisions
kind of confused the audience you know
in that in that specific script you know
so it's more about that but but yeah
well they say the writer reveals things
about themselves even if the story is
embellished even if it's not a true
story but they reveal who they are in
their character yeah you know I was
listening to an interview the other day
he had the day on NPR and and it was
with a writer I can't remember her name
but she was talking about writing and
and and and what she said resonated with
me you know because I think the person
interviewing her was like who are these
people that you're writing and she said
they're me every single character is me
and I think that's really true for me as
well
you know I think even though I'm writing
a different character per se whether
they are young or old or male female or
whatever you know they are really kind
of me because number one I've said all
the lines you know and when I write I
say all the lines out loud you know and
so I said all the lines and I've thought
about all the different subtext and so
it's really me you know it's it's sort
of my understanding of the world even if
it's from a different perspective per se
you know so yeah I think I think whether
an audience things that you're revealing
something about them I'm not sure but
but you definitely get some view of the
person writing the story you know
you